okay hey everyone it's Michael BOS from
orderflows and this is the orderflows
market analysis for Tuesday June 13 2017
now the markets rallied ahead of
tomorrow's or Wednesday's fomc meeting
with the Dow gaining about
0.4% to close around 21
328 there was a PPI came out which
uh
showed little headline strength uh but a
good gain for X energy and X food um
core rate that highlights the strength
in Services now again you know it's
there was some action in the orderflow
around the PPI just after it came out
the markets uh bond market sold off and
um but again you know it's it's on it's
on the day when the fomc Starts Now if
you remember you know everyone you know
a month ago is calling for a hike in I
say everyone but you know the sort of
the consensus was with people talking
people in the thing um three hikes later
this year
um back in April back in May and you
know we're June and we got the meeting
so you know it's not far out of the
realm to think that there might be a
possible uh Tongue Tied here a possible
hike um coming out on Wednesday so but
again you know we'll see I I haven't
looked at the FED funds um to see you
know what's being priced in or not again
you know
I I hate say my interest is in this
whole Comey sessions Trump thing you
know I'm really getting tired of it you
know just get over over at everybody and
you know there DC is full of a bunch of
crooks and you know let's just move on
with our lives you know it's really
becoming a pitiful uh T you know at
first I was very excited about it um you
know I thought it was great
entertainment but you know now it's just
all partisanship you know with you know
Democrats against Republicans and nobody
wants to work together you know if they
really wanted to go after the criminals
there there's a lot of criminals they
could go after there in
DC so you know briefly this this go
through the disclaimer this presentation
for educational and informational
purposes only and should not be
considered a solicitation of buy or sell
a Futures Contract or make any other
type of investment decision Futures
training contain substantial risk and is
not for every investor investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's Financial Security or lifestyle
only risk Capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk Capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results now again
you know I go through that disclaimer
every day as I start my presentation and
you know there's a reason for it um you
know there's no easy money in the
markets you know I know people would
like to think there is but um you know
there just an article that came out the
other day where hedge funds are closing
at an alarming rate you know almost uh
as much as what closed in 2008 you know
when we had the financial crisis so that
just gives you an idea of how difficult
it can be in the markets you know it's
not all um you know Happy Days you open
up the window and it's raining cash no
not at all you know I think probably at
at theate these hedge funds are are
closing doors they cannot match the um
returns in in the simple you know just
putting your money in in a simple uh
index fund that um you know probably a
year from now you'll be reading about
how you know these former star hedge
fund managers are now driving for Uber
or something like that so anyway you
know the tools used in this presentation
are the overflows Trader and the Delta
scalper
and you know trading what trading comes
down to is you know making decisions in
the market again you know there there
was another article I read um CNBC was
talking about it it was on cnbc's
website I should find the article about
how few Traders there are nowadays it's
a lot of the trading is done by machines
you know by alos and then people wonder
why um you know they can't match Alpha
you got all these different alos
competing for the same small Alpha
whereas you know the people that the
fundamental Traders you know the people
that actually sit there and make
decisions you know it's only about 10%
in the Market these days so you know
it's not that trading is becoming so
difficult that it's that you can't make
money but rather you know the the ones
that you know are going to I think going
to survive in the market longer you know
are the people that are able to make
decisions for themselves rather than
relying on some um black box to make a
decision will black boxes be around of
course they will you know one of the
biggest hedge funds Reen Renaissance um
Jim Simmons you know his fund's been
around for you know 30 years you know
and he's all blackbox stuff you know
he's all
mechanical so that's not to say that you
know Mechanicals you know these alos and
robots are going to compete against each
other and knock themselves out you know
some there will always be some in there
but again you know I think that to
succeed as a Trader you know you got to
make your own decisions and you know
orderflow has been around for a hundred
years you know well over 100 years you
know you go back you read reminiscence
of a stock operator and the guy was was
a was basically an orderflow Trader um
you know he's a tape reader um you know
it's what you know the older term is is
tape reading but you know it's reading
you know what's coming into the market
what's trading and you know what's the
the basic perception of the market based
on what's actually trading in the market
so anyway uh let's jump
into the markets uh really quick so you
know first one I'll talk about is bonds
now yesterday in the
bonds you you had a low and a high you
went from your low to your high where
you had a ratio and a Divergence now
today was similar but different you went
from your low to your high came off from
your high as well but you didn't have a
ratio and a Divergence rather what you
had is is something that I I can't get
my screen to shorten up here give me a
second there we go um but it it's
literally the same I'll say the same
thing but it it's it's close to this ah
my M computer is acting up
here
okay come on work with
me um so normally what I talk about is a
racial and Divergence but what I also
find a very effective trade is when you
have the bar with a Divergence and the
next bar you have a ratio to me that's
still a trade you know it's still what
I'm looking for because you know
sometimes you just don't get it in that
actual bar that you had the Divergence
so in the bonds yesterday at uh 835 you
had your low bar and you have a
Divergence you don't have the ratio it's
8.5 77 next bar you do have the ratio
the blue number 327 okay and you start
your rally you go from your low up to
your
highs oh this machine is driving me up
the wall
here just bear with me here it's a
little slow I got I got a lot of stuff
running on this PC right now um but
anyway so you went for me your
ratio with sorry your Divergence with
the ratio and the bar afterwards right
up to a new high with the Divergence and
the ratio afterwards and you came off
again
now ideally I'd like to have the ratio
and the Divergence in the bar you don't
always get it right because for whatever
reason there's bu just not enough volume
that's why I I I'm still interested in
it even if the ratio follows up in the
next bar now yesterday in the snps in
the 10 range chart
you had a high you had the high early in
the session and you had
um a ratio and a Divergence the next bar
though you know we just took a long time
spinning around in in then that bar here
you could see it um right here this is
the 10 range e- mini chart again I
apologize my my computer's a little got
a lot of stuff running on it right now
that's why it's a bit
slow
um where am I here okay
so here in this bar
851 here's your Divergence here's your
ratio but this next bar here this 933
bar you trade 154,000 contracts you
trade you know three times your amount
and you're putting in some very heavy
volume you know you can see in here
you're getting you know 13,000
14,000 do you come off yeah you come off
I don't like that you spend a lot of
time in here honestly um I was in this
was during the room session yesterday
when this bar was forming I lik this
show with the Divergence I didn't like
that you spent next 45 minutes just
spinning around in there you know to me
I lose my patience I really expect the
move to happen relatively sooner rather
than later um after we finish this bar
then we got the move this is the move I
was looking for I expected it to happen
right here but you just spun around in
here you know people came in and we're
happy to trade at this price this is
933 um you know early in the morning you
know before the sessions testimony
before um you know as fmc's just getting
started so you know I mean people are
they're doing what the market is there
for they're exchanging um transferring
risk from you know one party to another
party and then um later 1042 you got
Delta scalper here you know do I like it
that it's right going into the high I
you know I mean you can trade I prefer
it to be you know say this to be the low
of the day and you get the signal but
you know I still got to respect it you
know whether I take this trade or not
the other thing I like is that you have
Delta increasing you go you know you're
coming down here Delta's weakening it's
two- 2 ,000 - 1200 then it's plus 1,700
plus 2,000 plus 6,000 so I know at this
point that buyers are coming into the
market aggressively right you have
positive strong positive Delta the
Market's starting to rally and you're
coming into the highs you hit the high
hit new highs keep going higher um for
the rest of the day um right now in in
the mornings it's it's about 300 in the
morning is I'm recording this um you
know we're just right off of yesterday's
high
but again you know that was a ratio with
you know here you have a ratio with
Divergence you know it's right on the
cash close do you want to take it it's
up to you um did it come off not really
just sort of went just been going
sideways right now um and speaking of
Delta scalper crude
oil crude oil had had a nice uh signal
right on on the low there with um the
Delta scalper and I remember you know I
should talked a little B bit about it in
the room you know where you want to be
taking buys and where you want to be
taking sells and everyone says take
things in context of the market well
what exactly does that mean take things
in context of the market well it's
simple if you're looking to buy buy at a
low price you know buy below value if
you're looking to sell sell above value
um you know it's as simple as going into
the grocery store to buy a bottle of of
you know Coke or Pepsi right like you
know it's going to cost you you know 2 L
bottle is going to cost you two bucks
but if you can buy it all of a sudden
for one Buck a dollar you're going to
buy you know you might even buy more you
might even buy two or three you know I
know I would you know toilet paper right
you know you're going to use toilet
paper so if all of a sudden you know the
case of toilet paper the pack of toilet
paper you buy is normally $6 all of a
sudden it's you know two for $6 you're
going to buy two right because it's
below value you're going to you're going
to stock up on it and the market
concepts are are the same way so you
this was a market right we're going we
crude oil right we're selling off right
at this point this is 9 in the morning a
lot of imbalances I I was talking about
this in the room imbalance imbalance All
These Bars a lot of imbalances okay
they're not stacked but you know they're
sort of spread out in the bars but you
know it's still telling me there there's
a lot of selling and you're watching the
Deltas - 700 - 800 -300 - 800 - 700 then
you get down into this low area right so
you have a supply driven Market there's
a lot of supply coming into the market
pushing it lower gets down here Delta
scalper gives this Buy Signal right on
the low of the day
4556 you know so I know you know what
the Delta scoer does is it picks up
shifts in supply and demand and now it's
telling me hey we're potentially
shifting into a demand driven market now
where would you rather be buying it
would you rather be taking a Buy Signal
down here at the low or would you rather
be taking it you know at the high of the
day if you're shifting from a supply
driven Market to a demand driven Market
ideally you want to be buying it at the
lower end of the day and what happens is
you know if you bought it you're buying
it around
4566 you know then we we put in this
nice rally up up up up up up you know up
above 46 bucks see just all buying you
come all the way up into new highs 46 46
so you know it was that was you know if
you had one trade to take that day you
know that was it you you do have some
selling imbalances up here near the
highs
you know do I like it yeah I I do you
know I like this I don't like the fact
that just you know if I took this stack
selling imbalance it came right back on
me on the next bar sto me out um you
start getting up here you got some
imbalances but again it comes right back
with buying imbalances so you got to be
careful um even though I do like um you
know getting short off stacked
imbalances you know here is a nice
stacked imbalance right off this High
the third you know third times a charm
um before it came off and you know where
we trading right now
in the evening session um you know we're
trading here 46 oh back down to
4572 um next market I'll talk about is
beans I'll just mix it up a bit here
again um where do you want to be taking
buys and sells you ideally you want to
be taking Buys near low areas and sells
near High areas does it have to be the
high the day no can it be a swing high
of course it can um you know here's a
perfect example
soybeans my chart will come in
here
so
8:00 um we have a ratio within
Divergence you don't really come off
okay so so being sorry about that the
doorbell ring um I had to fix something
here now Divergence with the ratio sells
off a little bit not not much I'm not
going to consider this a big victory um
then just s goes sideways comes back up
towards your high again um is not a
Divergence this is a it's telling me
that there's some guys you know kind of
Trapped up here you got this
imbalance you do have a bearish ratio as
well another bearish ratio and then it
comes into this bar here at 910 with
this ratio of 1068 and you've got this
438 Lots traded here on the bid this is
an imbalance right it's red and to me
that's kind of important right you have
support in the market it's showing you
that there's support down here at this
level people are coming in hey you know
you got a lot of bearish signals up here
um but the other thing you got to you
know take note of is you got a very
bullish signal here you got support
coming in 438 where else do you see that
sort of size you see it back here 440 is
actually the same level so you know at
this price area you've got support you
you got point of control point of
control point of control comes right
back up imbalance here imbalance here
imbalance here so all these people that
are selling it trying to get it to go
lower because you know for whatever
reason you know I I think there's
bearish reasons up here to be getting
short but it's running into support and
you know at some point people are
selling the [__] out of it thinking [__]
I can't get any lower and okay screw it
I got to get out
and Market starts ring um you you get up
here to your high of the day 9:45 you've
got a Delta scoper giving you a cell so
again you know where would you want to
be taking cells ideally you want to be
taking up near the highs here you got a
nice stacked and balance afterwards but
you know really right up here you got
Divergence you got the Delta scalper
unfortunately it's not a ratio that you
like um point of control up near the top
that's this Aqua line telling me that
and what do you do you come off from you
know the 940 area boom boom boom kind of
go sideways down to the 939 938 area and
then boom Delta scalper again you
getting these kind of smallish R uh
deltas 3968 8 28
3317 but now it's picking it up Delta
scoper is picking it up that hey you
know what based on what just happened
here selling is coming in and what
happens goes from 939 this area 938 you
trade all the way down to um you know
just off your lows here you know this is
pretty much of a a straight line over
the next 15 minutes down to the 933 area
um later in the day around the close you
do make um new lows barely by uh two
cents uh sorry um two ticks and you know
in the night session we do rally back up
here you've got
a you know this is what time 3:30 in the
morning right
now you you got imbalance on the top you
got a bearish ratio but you don't have a
Divergence
there
Market I know why my computer is acting
up because i' I got this update that I'm
supposed to I just haven't been clicking
on it um that's why you know it my
computer wants to restart itself but I
I've been overriding it overwriting it
um that's that's why it's acting up this
as I'm recording this it wants to uh do
an update you know sometimes these
updates really mess up uh
everything but anyway um you know we'll
talk about here in the the euro currency
really quick and you know I trying to
remember what there was okay so again
you know here going back to 3 in the
morning yesterday
okay you have the Delta scoper giving
you a sell but it's a sell on a green
bar right if you're getting short you
don't want to getting short on a green
bar want be getting short on a red bar
um you come off here it's just it's
there honestly in the euro currency
there wasn't a whole lot to really get
excited about because you're sort of
trading in a Range most of the day I did
find this low kind of interesting you
know you had a nice swing low here with
a ratio point of control near the
bottom green bar with a negative Delta
so it's telling me you know hey this
this Market could be turning here and it
did it turned but mostly went sideways
over the next
hour um you know it did pop back up
around 950 here you got a swing high
with
um a bearish ratio price rejector single
print I would have liked this bar a lot
more had it been a negative Delta rather
than the positive Delta by we have the
positive Delta is because there's a lot
of volume traded up here on the offer
you know in my early days of trading
order flow I used to trade the market
from you know areas
like what we just saw on that low that's
why I said I was interested in this low
because there's some decent volume
trading down here towards the bottom of
the bar you know a swing low 100 150 82
and then you got the single print down
there and then you rally up here to this
High where you got the single print you
got 98 195 160 that's how I used to
trade orderflow back in you know years
ago um you to me this is just Market
generated support and resistance levels
I know as we're coming up here there's
some sellers up here okay buying is kind
of drying up on on the way
up and you know so I I would just trade
it for you know what I could get out of
the trade there wasn't any necessarily
any any Rhyme or Reason to it I was just
trading you know what I thought was
Market generated support or resistance
levels you know for
example if this screen would cooperate
here um this bar
here again you know we come off we
bounce up a bit and I can see 135 307
313 I know there sellers up here sort of
holding their foot on the market you
know and you know so that's why we're
not going higher and to me this is a
legitimate short opportunity right there
and you know the market did come off you
get down here you have this dogee bar
with the Delta
scalper again I'm not a big fan of
taking trades on dogee bars but again
you know did this one work out yeah but
I I find this this bar more interesting
actually with the 154 284 185 this
volume down here supporting this market
and you pop back up here
um lastly I just talk about
the um give me a sec
here let's talk about the japen real
quick if I could find my
chart okay here it is so again right uh
right before the number came out this
morning 724 you had this nice bar this
nice swing High here with the ratio with
an imbalance on the top and point
control right at the top you know it
just sort of sticks out there like you
know like I say like a cross or anything
like that you know but and then the
market sold out I love these types of
bars you know it's just unfortunate it
happens right as the numbers about to
come out but I I love this you all every
day I see this and it's a great shorting
opportunity you got point of control
right at the top you got a bearish ratio
as well um 301 forward so this is one's
the ratio bounds low and you know
there's not much more I can say about it
I mean that's I see that all the time
and to me it's just great trading
opportunities I I can't um you know get
into it
here um you know in the sense that you
know what else can I say about something
that I talk about every single day you
know but um here you got the Delta
scoper given a sell this one didn't work
out it came right back up and even in
the next bar you got a stack buying and
balance then you get up here to the
swing high it's not a ratio but some
decent volume being traded here 3,900
and know you know this is right around
the the European close 10:00 cash
European cash close so you do see
sometimes a bit of more volume coming in
around that time um sometimes people's
you know their alos end at that time and
right afterwards Delta scal were giving
you a sell so why you have one here that
failed on you but again the signs were
there that it's not working out when you
see this uh stack buying IM
balance but then again you know don't
kick yourself oh I took this trade and I
lost you know then don't take the next
trade you know don't have that negative
thinking you know you know part of being
a successful Trader is is being a
positive thinker not a negative thinker
um you know dwelling on your losses you
know if anything just put it behind you
say okay yeah I had a loss now hope the
next trade should come around for me and
you know should be a winner you know
that's how I look at it you know I I
like to be optimistic in life um rather
than than a negative thinker so anyway
Delta scalper giving you a sell here and
you know so whatever you lost on this
previous trade you know it it's giving
you another trade to get it back on now
here okay so we sort of round out here
come down to these lows start getting
some small volume uh Deltas here 11 11
um work your way back up going you know
this is already just before 1:00 this
1240 Delta scop we're giv a sell but
it's a red bar sorry it's a green bar
you don't want to be taking sells on
green bars where the bar turns around
late and closes
higher and then up here you know 130
2:00 2:00 you got the Delta scalper
giving you a cell here you have the
Delta Sur
usually actually the Delta scalper gives
the signal before the Delta surge but in
this case you do have the Delta scalper
here and Delta surge right here then
again you got another Delta scalper
given a sell here and you know we sold
off from there so you know while there
was you saw three trades just you know
these three trades you know this this
one here is a loser this one is a nice
winner this one is not a trade because
it's a green bar this one is a red bar
which is the one you want to take and
you know you sell off going into the
night session um you know then again you
know 1:30 in the morning Chicago time
Delta scal were giving a sell here you
know people ask can I trade in the
evening session uh I tend to stick away
stay away from um the Asian session
unless I'm trading like nikai or or palm
oil but you know that's you I don't even
talk about those markets in in here
because most people don't trade those um
sort of a hold over because I used I
traded those markets for you know 15
years of my life I spent 10 years in
Singapore and even before that when I
was working trading in Chicago working
in Chicago you know I I work Asian hours
uh that Asian hours European hours I'd
start about 10:00 at night and finish up
at 8: in the
morning it's great working nights
actually um you could you just be
yourself you know working an office
during the day especially in a in a bank
you got to be very politically correct
you can't you can curse and swear um but
it's really you know it's not like the
movies where you see you know see this
that movie um money never sleeps you
know Wall Street number part two and you
go to the trading floor and everyone's
you think it's it's open outcry trading
pits everyone's hand signaling you go to
a trading floor in a bank um majority of
them you know I'm not going to say all
of them but the majority of them it's
it's like being in a freaking Library
you know you you yell and scream and
people will hear you and stick their
heads up wondering why who's yelling and
screaming um but
anyway so you know you can trade
currencies you can trade most CME
products European hours meaning you know
one 1 2 in the
morning you know one or two Chicago time
until you know until the Chicago close
here's a nice sell this is 1:30 in the
morning Delta scalper right afterwards
Delta surge giving you the sell and you
know we come off from uh
9090 area down to new lows at
9070 um 9073
9074 so anyway um you know that's it for
today and again you know I'll be
interested to see you know if the
Market's going to be quiet uh today on
on Wednesday it's I said you know it's
you got the announcement coming out at
1:00 Chicago time and again I haven't
checked what the FED funds are doing but
um you know how how people are slanted
but again you know people are always
have been talking you know for the last
couple years actually people been
talking about every year you're going to
do three or four rate hikes last year
would you get one or two um this year I
think one can't remember remember now if
you had one my brain is fried at this
time but anyway right now our range in
the S&P is 35 low um 39 and 3/4 High
which you know is pretty recent actually
so you know coming into the morning it's
3:30 in the morning 340 in the morning
and you've got basically a fiveo not
even a fivepoint range you know four and
3/4 Point range so you it'll probably be
quiet quiet early morning um so we'll
see what brings what comes up to that so
anyway um again you know tools use I use
is the orderflows trader which is the
volume footprint and I talk a lot about
the Delta scalper I'm talking with my
programmer for the nt8 version we might
um put in
a delta scalper in there um in a
slightly modified form we're going to
make a couple one or two changes I want
to make to it um just to bring it up
I'll say bring it up to date but one of
the changes I want to make to it is the
um if you you know I talk about not
taking signals not taking buys on R bars
or not taking cells on green bars I want
to put that in it and you know what we I
want I'm trying to convince them to let
me put it into the nt8 version so we'll
see where that goes but um so thanks for
watching this and go to my website
orderflows
docomo so thanks everyone and have a
good day bye-bye